les temples
malbar après l'abolliition de
l'esclavage
48 des travailleurs libres désignés sous
le nom d'engagés arrivent d'Afrique
d'Inde et de Chine pour travailler dans
les grandes propriétés sucrières de
l'île les engagés hindou comme
préciseent leur contrat de travail
obtiennent l'autorisation d'élever des
temples pour pratiquer leur culte les
premiers apparaissent dans les camps à
proximité des sucreries comme au ga ou
au caserern à
Saint-Pierre à la fin du 19e siècle
d'autres temples sont construits dans
les principau palville de la colonie ils
tranchent aussi par leur simplicité
extérieure avec l'architecture
religieuse du sud de
l'Inde à partir des années 1950 apparaît
un nouveau style les décors jusque- là
réservés à l'intérieur vont se
multiplier sur les murs
extérieurs plus monumentaux plus coloré
les temples hindou deviennent également
plus visibles dans le paysage
réunionné les années 1990 marquent une
étape
importante transformé agrandi
reconstruit de nombreux temples adoptent
les canons de l'Inde du
Sud le décor sculpté souligné par une
riche polychromie devient omnipr
donnant une unité esthétique à
l'ensemble de ces édifices
religieux cinq d'entre eux parmi les
plus anciens sont protégés au titre des
Monuments
Historiques